hello folks and welcome to
rational science directly from frankfurt
germany
uh we have a great day today we're going
to be talking about
space time we finally get there
uh we've been doing a little bit of
geometry
as a stepping stone
a series you know that serves as a
stepping stone to
space times today we're we finally got
there anyways before i
get to space time let's cover a little
bit of extinction we had some
questions and comments let's start there
first uh fellow says first thing that
struck me was the
weight of all the water on that thing
he's referring to this
referring to the stanford taurus
okay the idea that spindly
uh construction could contain all that
loose mass along with all the soil and
the rest of it made my brow
wrinkle yeah you got water in there you
got land
you got buildings you got to construct
the buildings right
there's a lot of stuff there but
remember this is an outer space out
there where there's no
gravity and so uh
i don't know how much uh water and all
this stuff
weighs uh remember the the way they
produce artificial gravity on this thing
is they rotate it it's a it's a
um what is it a torus that spins in
space
okay and so you know how much it weighs
depends on how fast you spin it uh
and you do have to spin it in order to
cause this artificial gravity
okay that the in other words they mimic
gravity remember we have a difference in
rational science we say that gravity and
and force of
push is not necessarily the same thing
okay one is pushed the other one is pull
that's the difference between the um
principle of equivalence
okay and so i've covered that in the
past i'm not going to get into that now
but just keep that in mind
uh the artificial gravity there
creating here is made through push and
gravity is a pull force
okay so there's a little bit of
difference under the rope model
okay next issue a fella along the same
lines he says
i sent it on the other side i can't
believe that give me a second here
well it says says
where is your intergenerational where in
your
inter-generational taurus spacecraft
argument did you explain why a fusion
reactor could not provide the energy to
sustain life away from a star
um well remember the model
is not mine the model comes from
stanford it was commissioned by nasa
and it's designed to live here in the
solar system
in other words it's got all these solar
panels that
provide the energy okay and uh the solar
panel is a big portion
of this so-called taurus that will
supposedly keep people in
in space around inside the solar system
now when we talk about intergenerational
travel like to the nearest star
uh three-star system known as centauri
uh you have alpha beta and proxima
and these three stars form this this uh
system and we are 4.3 light years away
from the nearest one of those which is
proxima
okay that's what it's called
approximately the approximate one
and you know you're talking about 4.3
light years away meaning traveling at
the speed of light we reached there in
4.3
light years one way a round trip would
be
close to nine years okay but what is the
issue the issue
is that we don't travel at the speed of
light never will
will travel somewhat slower than that in
fact i would say
much slower than that okay i don't even
think we're going to be able to travel
at the tenth of the speed of light
which is what the light sails are
supposed to be
doing but light sails only work again
within the solar system and
the farther away they get the less push
you get from the sun
you know i'm not sure you can do much
with that uh
between here and uh proxima so
again you know uh yeah can you power it
with um
with nuclear reactors yeah you can but
keep in mind you know
nuclear reactors don't last forever and
so the issue there
and besides the danger it is you know
you don't want to blow everybody up in a
million pieces
so you know there are a lot of
considerations there but assuming you
know we've got it under control
etc you know you still have to take uh
several reactors there okay and maybe
run them in tandem or
in series and again you're talking about
intergenerational
okay uh first of all it's crazy to think
something like that especially for the
people we have
on earth today uh nobody gives
their lives for their great grandsons
you know and here this is what they're
going to have to be doing they're going
to have to
think not in themselves they're never
going to make it they're going to live
the rest of their lives in space
their children will live all their lives
in space their children will live all
their lives in space and maybe
maybe some great grandson down the road
reaches
proxima centauri now that's a long trip
and you know the question is whether
anyone has a stomach for that kind of
thing
you know it's never going to happen
realistically
it's never going to happen okay but yeah
you could power it cons assuming you
don't do it with
humans you can do it with robots right
so we don't have to worry about
intergenerational anything there we just
send the robots over
aside from the cost of such an
expedition which be
would uh bankrupt the entire earth uh
you know can you send them with uh with
uh
nuclear power yeah i guess you could uh
all the way down there you know
the question is again what for are you
going to send them to explore
are you going to send them to prepare
colonization for humans
and in that case are we going to
evacuate the earth and
send billions of people to that other
star
you got to think about all this you know
it's it's nonsense to say that we're
going to go out into space
it's nice to watch star trek and all
that fantasy stuff
it's great i love it but
for that to take it into the serious
business and say that that's
science oh my that's a big step big step
for mankind there okay
okay next uh issue that this gentleman
raises
where in your economic extinction
scenario
did you explain what happened to all the
food gathered from the last harvest
that would normally last until the next
harvest
okay i think it's a good question um
first of all uh that food is not under
your control okay
someone knows where all that food is
but it's not you okay and someone has
control over that food and it's not you
it's not
not everyone in the city in fact no one
in the city controls that food someone
outside
the city probably controls it uh there
are some warehouses with food
you know we know that from the russian
revolution they attacked the warehouses
and just stole everything they could
and when that was gone well you know
then you had to rely on the farms to
provide you
with food and that's when the communist
government would send
uh you know the armies out there to
expropriate
food from the peasants and
uh in this case you know you got all
these corporations they've got the food
but you know they control it but if
there's no money why will they
deliver it why will they
sell it if there's nothing that you can
use to
exchange for that food when all the
money in the world collapses the only
thing of value
is food and people don't understand that
people say no i'm going to trade i'm
going to trade my
my dog or my goldfish for
for food now it's not going to happen
people don't understand when money
collapses food
is no more no one produces trades food
because food is the only thing
that's of value and uh whoever
worked for these corporations
agricultural corporations or the food
processing corporations
they probably know where the food is and
they're going to make sure that nobody
else does
that's the way it works so it doesn't
matter if
they store some food out there in fact
there's a study that said there's only
three months worth of food out there in
the world today
uh at any given point in time and
you can imagine why that's the case you
know you you can't have too much food
because it throws the price
prices down that's one issue and then
the other one is you have to distribute
it you know
slowly like you know send it to the uh
outlets like uh supermarkets and so on
and you don't send it all at the same
time now you send it you know
as they need it as it's ordered so
there's a
flow of food essentially you know
from the producer to the production
companies to the distributor
to the supermarkets and then to the
consumer so it's a flow okay it's a flow
and the question here is
will the flow stop and you say well
there's food out there yeah but
again it's not in your hands and there's
no reason for them to give it to you
at all and you know i'm sure that you do
right now if i ask you where is all that
food you probably don't know and you
probably don't care because you say hey
you know i'm going to the
supermarket tomorrow and get my food
like you know here we have in germany we
have what are known as klein gardens
and they're uh small gardens and
everybody has like a plot of land 300
400 square meters and
the owner or the manager of uh the klein
garden where
i have my plot of land he once told me
that
two of his sons you know they didn't
want to work at the klein guard at the
uh
you know the garden and he said you know
you should
love the land you should plant you
should grow things you know
and he said you know you can grow
potatoes here and say
potatoes dad i can get potatoes
at the supermarket why would i want to
grow potatoes
so that's the kind of answer you get
okay people are not even aware they take
food for granted
and so a great majority of people will
not even think
about growing food until it's too late
at that point
all they have is you know the gun that's
it violence or or just uh
steel go to a farm and eat whatever you
can like the locust
okay another issue
fellow says you said that the cause of
mass extinction
is the trade no more there's going to be
no trade yeah
what are the mechanisms by which this
trade should be
interrupted well you know i explained in
the past here let me put it up here
uh you got to do extinction 101 before
you do
extinction 102 and the reason for that
is right now we're stuck at that point
that is
martin green food disappears if money
disappears
lots of people do not understand that
they cannot and i'm just saying that
they don't believe it it's just that
they don't understand it
because this is not something to believe
here's a big if there it says if money
disappears food disappears
and people don't understand that they
they have trouble
so you got to do extinction 101 before
you do extinction 102 which is
again you know extinction 101 is that
you got to explain mass extinctions
you gotta figure out how the
animals in the past died that's the
issue before us
okay and then uh the other issue this uh
fellow raises
uh as a direct consequence of this
supposed interruption money would lose
confidence
you know people lose confidence in money
but i guess that's what he meant
his english is not the best i'll be
generous here as much as i can and
therefore disappear
in how many generations do you think it
could happen
uh for this you got to define the word
generation
and so i i've written uh quite a bit on
that in fact uh
there's the site where you can look up
on google just google that
you stupid relativist.com look for
extinction
and the first page the first
module is what is a generation
so you can read it there you'll have
you'll find your answer in there
you got to define what a generation is
okay and
we have different notions of what a
generation is
for example did uh galileo
and newton belong to the same generation
they were both
living in the 17th century
but you know galileo died
the year newton was born were they
of the same generation okay so you got
questions like that first you got to
answer what is a generation then you can
answer the question
okay another issue
yeah after humanity has almost
eliminated it
eliminated itself do you have any
percentage to propose
uh i think it's the same fellow i guess
he's saying you know what percentage
uh the global population will survive
he's i guess that's what his question is
uh i think there's gonna be pockets
here and there someone's gonna survive
in one country another one in another
you know there's gonna be pockets in
cities and in the country wherever
i think there are gonna be pockets of
people who survive
uh i don't think any lone person will
survive
you can't survive all by yourself some
people think they're gonna do
survivalist uh
stuff you know get a backpack a gun and
go hunt
mental people you know they have no clue
no you don't you don't you're not going
to survive with your gun out there in
the forest or the jungle
okay and too lengthy to explain if you
can't understand it well sorry
and then uh then you have the those are
the survivalists then you have the other
people who are the people who
plan to have a garden okay
and um and they're the preppers okay and
the preppers what do they do they
prepare
what are they preparing for we have no
clue whatsoever
okay they're preparing and the way they
prepare they think they're prepared
they're training themselves
to be prepared for any catastrophe uh
among them you know nuclear exchanges
etc
and the way they prepare is they learn
how to plant
and grow a garden or or have a farm or
whatever
and if they think they're gonna survive
that they're gonna because they're
prepared they're
really mistaken grossly mistaken because
people from the cities are gonna overrun
their farms anyone who's got a farm man
better get the hell out of there
that's the way it is you don't wait for
a gun and say oh i'm gonna fight these
thousand people from the city or a
million people from the city
that come to raise you know my my farm
doesn't work that way the way it is you
gotta hide you better get your tail out
of there because
people are just gonna swarm over your
farm and eat whatever there is
on it and you can kill as many as you
can
and people also are going to become come
over
armed you know because they know there's
going to be trouble but even if they
came without
weapons you know you're going to be
killing a lot of people you're going to
have a lot of fun
just doing turkey shooting there
so now the best way is to run away don't
don't
don't do this like the fox do it like
the rabbit
do you think a new species will take
over uh yeah
when there's a mass extinction there's
another species that always becomes
takes over and becomes the apex predator
after
the new species uh you know squat
uh different niches okay so
that's always happened and i don't see
why it won't happen after the mammals
are gone because this is the extinction
of the mammals the sixth
mass extinction the sixth biggest mass
extinctions there were some smaller mass
extinctions
along the way okay but uh so i answer
that the cycle repeats itself until at
some point
all life on earth disappears okay
the earth is not going to be there
forever um you know you've got
a runaway greenhouse that might come
along in the future
leave us looking more like venus than
like the earth today
and so you know i think there at some
point all life will disappear
on earth and again we're not getting out
of here so guess what
you know that will be the final um
stone you could say on the on the uh
on on the uh uh on the on the
on life itself in other words life will
not go beyond that
that'll be the end of life on earth no
plants no animals no anything
so at some point i think you know
anything that's living
that's moving against gravity that's the
definition of living
um you know moves no more
not not by itself okay and there will be
a species of plants and species of
animals that turns out the light
on earth there will be a last species of
both plants
and animals okay next issue
fella says with a new
i think the same guy uh would a new
human repopulation
repopulate the planet as has already
happened with neanderthals
or chrome magnums chromanium and
others well we are the last
of the hominids hominins whichever word
you want to use
uh the hominins and the hominins
we're the last dynasty there's no
uh other animal close to us
out there other you know chimps and
gorillas you know on the big apes
baboons and so on but we are essentially
we can't
we can't interbreed with them okay so we
are really
a specific line and here you see a
little uh
map of that little chart okay
uh you know we're the last of our last
lineage that uh of which neanderthal was
you know our
cousin and he was the last of our
cousins and now we have no more cousins
now we have long lost cousins you could
say like the champs and gorillas and so
on
but i'm not sure we're going to mate
with them or that we could even mate
with them
and so right now all we can do is
whittle ourselves away our genetic
diversity
all we can do is lose it and so yeah
much like the t-rex
was the last of the tyrannosaurus and
possibly the last of their theropods
okay
all the dynasties of apex predators end
up with the last member especially in a
mass extinction event
and that's what uh we can expect we we
we can expect being the last
of the harmonies homonym whatever you
want to call it
we have no one to mate with and there's
only two ways to
get genetic diversity and that is go to
a new environment
you know and and have the environment
you know chisel uh new genetic diversity
into you because you're in a
radically different environment and or
else mary
you know a chimp and i don't recommend
that one
you're going to marry someone who's got
very different genetic
uh build up
as as you have and we can't do that
anymore
now you can say well maybe we can do it
you know in the lab
well good luck with that one we're going
to build some kind of frankenstein there
because whatever
changes you make if you're going to
really make changes in the human genetic
code it's going to be some something
very different than us
eventually you know you keep changing
changing changing something
at some point you know that guy won't be
able to marry you because he's so
different from you
so we stop being human become whatever
that thing is
okay some kind of monkey maybe who knows
so that's one issue
but again the only way you can you can
get genetic diversity is
the natural way is new environment
that's it
and no space is not a new environment
because we take
our environment from earth with us
same thing when we go to the north pole
we don't go nude like
uh neanderthal was you know when we go
to the north pole we
we take our codes and we take all our
protection
so no we don't we do not get exposed
over many centuries by the way many
generations
we do not get exposed to new
environments anymore
we're done we have no way of changing
our genetic code
and the other issue is diseases diseases
are the sifter
of genetic diversity the reason japanese
have the same genetic diversity
or the same amount of genetic diversity
or are very little genetically
are very little genetic very
little different genetically than
americans or russians or
south americans and africans we're all
genetically alike
why because our great grandfathers our
grandfathers all
these people in the past they went
through the same sifter
the same diseases so it doesn't matter
if you're japanese or
african you get the same genetic code
today very
little difference between a japanese and
an african
for example a reno and an african a
russian and an american
why because we all went through the same
process
that's the reason and it's we're talking
about hundreds of years
okay what did the smallpox do it killed
all the
aztecs that weren't prepared for it or
who those who were lucky and didn't get
it
and those that survived are the ones
that are alive today
you look at a genetic code of mexican
today
and he's the same as a spaniard why
because they went through the same
process
so period we're done okay okay
uh another question also
related to genetic diversity a fellow
says
genetic diversity is overestimated by
bill uh-huh
in 1930 israel our herone uh
captured a female with seven cubs on the
plateau
of aleppo syria to establish a breeding
line for experiments
experimental animals of which only four
cubs three males and one female survived
these were multiplied at the hebrew
university of jerusalem
for a long time all other golden
hamsters in captivity descended from
them both experimental animals and pets
it seems uh the golden hamsters don't
know or
or don't care about genetic diversity
uh what you got to understand is that
first of all you haven't answered the
question i mean
you haven't told me if uh if those
hamsters have a difference in genetic
diversity maybe they're all alike maybe
they're all clones for all we know right
that's one issue but uh so
you know that's not there that
information is not there what you put up
there
but let me just state my case and that
is that genetic diversity is an issue
of how many times the earth went around
the sun for each species
okay and each species is different some
wipe out their genetic diversity much
faster
than others and here you see the case of
the neanderthals i
put a graph there that gives you an idea
how it was whittled over time
okay and uh if you looked at the
neanderthals that started out uh maybe
500 600
600 000 years ago again all these
numbers are very
you know don't put your hand in the fire
for them but
what they look at the bones okay of
these people they
they try to analyze whatever genetic
code they can
from from them and the
consensus now after looking at uh
there was a four-year study looking at
genetic diversity of neanderthals
and they lost it over time no doubt
about it if you get to
like 80 000 years ago where we have a
little more data than 300 or 400 000
years ago right
you get the 80 000 years ago there was
more genetic diversity among those
neanderthals those samples that we have
today than we did
than than they did when they reached
40 000 years ago you know around the
upper paleolithic
so in those 40 000 years the
neanderthals lost genetic diversity
and there you have a little graph that
just puts it in
you know in perspective we lose genetic
diversity if we go back in time
we would find that 200 000 years ago 100
000 years ago we had much more genetic
diversity
among humans even though we were a
smaller population than we do today
where we're 8 billion people
today we have no genetic diversity why
because we lose it
over time it's a question of how many
times the earth went around the sun
for each species for our species it went
very fast
went very fast because we were able to
conquer diseases and that didn't help us
at all it helped us
live but what it did was you know it
made us all
clones of each other whoever you marry
today is
genetically from a genetic point of view
your brother or your sister so it
doesn't matter that's why we're having
autis homosexuals and all kinds of
genetic
related problems yeah these people are
born that way
they didn't make themselves that way
which is the argument some people have
out there
okay uh here's uh another issue i think
you are mixing up the
mennonites with amesh yamiche owned guns
and hunt
there's even a case of an amish man
suing blah blah blah okay i've witnessed
them firsthand even compared weaponry
and talked
ammo with them many times uh yeah
this is out of context uh here's the
here's the context okay this is what
this fellow wrote
fellow says even the amish are armed
harm one a whole community comes down on
you
so what i was addressing not uh first of
all he got that probably from watching
you know
a series that was out there in 2017 that
made fun of the amish because they put
them with
all these guns now do amish own guns
well a few of them do
not many but a few of them do and what
they do is hunt
but they don't hunt people that's the
issue here
this father thinks that the amish are
going to come with their guns and kill
you because you killed one of theirs
one of their own no no they the amish
do not kill people they're it's part of
their religion you can slap them kill
them whatever and they won't do anything
you know
allow you to slap them and kill them
because they think it's against the
rule of god to take vengeance on another
human being
and i don't know i've never heard of a
case
where a an amish killed another amish or
what they call an englishman the guy
that's on the other side of the fence
i never heard of that but if you know of
a case i'd really like to know
okay so send me send me a case where an
amish
gunned down someone else and i
i doubt that ever happened okay okay
and then um final issue here
fella says okay so
some americans have already solved the
problem of um
again of of extinction or
salvation after extinction when most
people die
they have made their plan aha when the
[ __ ] hits the fan they will go to their
assigned posts
some will provide protection for the
farm with their guns aha
i wish them good luck and then others
will provide labor on the farm
i wish those good luck also why would
they provide labor
without any pay what are they they're
waiting to
collect on the uh on on harvest day or
what the hell what do you mean they're
going to labor on the farm
as long as the group can keep their
bubble safe they will survive
yeah very important point bubble save
can you
keep your bubbles safe and uh
the only good thing he said there is
farmers know they can't do it all by
themselves in that environment yeah
correct a 100 acre farm can feed 150
people
and 150 people protect 100 acres
is the question yes the question is how
do you protect
all that crop i mean you're really going
to have to
work 24 hours a day uh have a team that
controls all corners of your farm
they're all going to have to be armed
and they're going to have to be willing
to fight and die
because there's a lot of desperate
people out there who's gonna come to the
farm to
grab whatever they can and a lot of them
are gonna be armed
and maybe they're better shooters than
you are you know so
you never know maybe someone maybe you
have a little
musket and the other guy comes with a
machine gun or a cannon or
throws hand grenades you know i don't
know so you got to be careful about all
that
especially in the u.s it's got so many
weapons you know
here in europe at least nobody has
weapons very few people have weapons
over there
everybody's got one so it's going to be
a little different
history what's going to happen here as
to what happens over there
okay enough for extinction let's get
down to the
subject matter today which is space time
ever heard of space time well what we've
been doing this
uh these last couple weeks is uh doing a
little review of geometry and geometry
is what general relativity
the owners of space-time right what
they base their theory on
they base it on geometry it's a
geometric
theory it's known as a geometric theory
it's known as a geometric
theory of gravity so geometry plays an
important role
and that's one of the reasons i went
through this little
series that went from point to line to
circles and all the way up to tauruses
okay because all of that is really like
the foundation
of general relativity uh when you look
at the
people who created relativity it wasn't
just
good old einstein uh you had other
people there as well
and they all worked on this geometric
on the geometric
context that underlay uh what we have
today is general relativity
and so we gotta we have to start at
geometry no doubt about it
and here we go uh let me just do a quick
review of what
we did this month so that we can get it
all into proper context
point what is a point well this is what
they show you
they illustrate a little dot could be 2d
or 3d it doesn't matter usually it's 2d
because they just
hit the chalk on the on the uh board and
you're looking at it from a frontal yeah
it's got depth a
chalk has death but you're looking at
frontally so
it's 2d for all practical purposes but
that's what they
illustrate is that what a point is well
know what a point is is a location
and so and that's how they define it
that's how they describe it
and so there's nothing to illustrate for
what a point really is
okay so the word point is very
misleading because they show you a dot
but they mean location and there's
nothing to illustrate for location
and what they do is they use the dot to
represent pictorially represent the
location that's what's happening here
the dot belongs to physics the location
well i don't know who that belongs to it
also belongs to physics but
uh these people quantify locations uh
by saying that you need two coordinates
to establish a
location or one you know it depends on
whether you're doing linear or you're
doing a planar
or three-dimensional locations you know
then you
have you know triple triplets or you
have
ordered pairs or whatever depending on
what you're trying to do
but the point is that the
location of mathematics is not a
location it's not a qualitative
location what it is is a set of numbers
that tells you
where you are from some frame of
reference
that's what a point is okay
and again they never define it they say
it's primitive only because they're
trying to mix
physics the dot with the word location
what is a line well a line is a bunch of
locations
and so they say well it's one
dimensional but that's not what they
illustrate what they illustrate
is what you see there an elongated
rectangle
two-dimensional rectangle so both the
dot
and the line are two-dimensional what
what they put
on the board or on the paper because
there is no way to illustrate anything
below
two dimensions or above three
and so everything out there is either
two or three dimensional
every object out there there is no
object that is one or zero dimensional
there is no object that is four
dimensional
or above it's everything is two
or three dimension and so they
illustrate that line
and what do they mean well they mean a
bunch of locations they say it's one
dimensional
and what they're really talking about is
a bunch of locations and turns out the
location they say is zero dimensional
and with a bunch of zero-dimensional
locations
they form a one-dimensional line you
figure it out do
many zero dimensions form a
one-dimensional line
this is what you gotta ask yourself it
doesn't make sense uh the language is
wrong
the concept is wrong it's wrong because
again they're
they're describing and defining
mathematics
but they're illustrating physics that's
what's happening
okay what is it playing well a plane um
again it shows something like that
that's
one type of plane just one among
gazillions of planes that are out there
why didn't i put an illustration well i
didn't put an illustration because they
say that the plane is infinite in other
words
you never see the end you can't see a
plane
the definition the description of the
word plane you can't see it from a
bird's eye perspective
you don't see the edges of a plane
because the plane
like the line by the way are alleged to
be
infinite meaning it's still growing we
haven't finished constructing
the plane or the line and that's one of
the conceptual problems with all of
these okay
they just say it's infinite stretches
forever or extends forever so we don't
know what a plane is
not not the mathematical plane in
physics we know what a plane is
plane has borders all around it's got
shape
it's an object also known as a figure
synonym
okay what is a solid well again i didn't
draw it because a bunch of locations
and worse solid is hollow
all solids are hollows the only thing
you get is the skin
and you don't even get the skin what you
get is an itinerary
that goes throughout the whole uh
cylinder the whole
uh whatever three-dimensional
figure you're alluding to could be a
cube whatever or a
pyramid cone cylinder any of those
but what is it what you're doing really
is moving a little
location we can't even say it's a dot
you're moving a location around and
constructing it point by point so that
cell in there there
we all understand that in physics it's a
cylinder you know uh
it looks like my dough roller here you
know just the center of it
okay looks like that that's a cylinder
okay we got it
no it doesn't get more complicated than
that okay
but that's not what a cylinder is uh for
them for math because they describe and
define it
as a bunch of locations meaning that
there's a location that's moving around
and painting or constructing that
cylinder okay
again i have nothing to show for that uh
what is a circle well the same thing but
just a
show which also answers the questions of
the previous to the solid in the plane
a circle is a bunch of locations uh
that are equidistant from a center
that's it that's what uh
circle is so circle is not what you see
there on the
left that's what they illustrate and
then some people say well it's just the
ring
and if it's just the ring what are we
talking about how thin is the ring
how how wide is the location
because that's what they've got they've
got a bunch of locations
and they say well the circle is just the
ring but see this
the ring is nothing it's a bunch of
locations which is what you see there
and i was kind enough to leave the
different uh
locations there so that you can see
something otherwise you would just see
a dot going around and that's what a
circle is to a mathematicians
it's not uh it's distance traveled by
a uh a location if that makes any sense
to you
and semi-circle is the same thing but
half
it's half a circle so the dot or the
location travels
and stops at the other side half
half of the circle that's what it is you
figure it out see if that makes any
sense to you
and what is a spheres since we're on the
same road of
circular geometries
uh sphere is you take that semicircle
and you twirl it around
both uh euclid and modern mathematics
define it in the same way
you twirl a circle a semicircle around
so a sphere is not what you see there on
the left that's what they illustrate
that's what they show and people say oh
i understand that
that's not what a sphere is here is what
you see on the right
okay and that's just the starting point
uh it just gets more complicated as you
get to other
geometries here are the other geometries
a little more
complex maybe some of them okay and you
start with a square
which is not complicated but again uh
what is there to illustrate well
i don't know if you see that there's a
little dot going around okay
it's on the far right underneath the
green letters
so if you look carefully there you'll
see a little dots going around
and what it is again it's a it's not
even a perimeter
it's a it's a location traveling
around a perimeter that's what a square
is that's how it's defined and that's
how it's described
but that's not what they show what they
show is that red thing that
looks like a square there for physics
that's a square for
math that's what you get on the other
side uh this is what you order that's
what you get in the mail
[Laughter]
okay what is a cube well a cube is is a
bunch of frames window frames
okay empty window frames there's no
window in it in it just a frame
okay and we don't know how thick the
frame is i made them thick here so that
you could see the frame
okay but in real life uh
the way mathematics describes and
defines it
all you have is again just a little
dot that you see there on the square
and that's just tracing a perimeter that
is
around the square and then they build
the
cube with six of these so that little
dot has a lot of work to do
and just going around this perimeter
called a cube and
and it's hollow and it's got no windows
it's a frame
without a window okay so that's what a
cube
is in mathematics now that we're going
to take that and we're going to build
our
tesseract with that what is a tesseract
well they say it's a four-dimensional
object
but what you see there it's a
three-dimensional
pair of nested cubes or that that's more
or less what it looks like
okay that's more or less the idea that's
what you have objectively in front of
you
actually you have two
nested three-dimensional cues one big
one small
and they're superimposed okay so that
you can see the center one
they're transparent so again so that you
can see the center one
and they both of them are superimposed
on a
2d platform so the notion here is that
you have a 3d
pair of cubes projected onto
a 2d platform that's what we have
objectively on
up there in front of us i don't care
what they talk
in high school i don't care how they
define or describe it i'm saying that's
what we have objectively
in front of us hopefully you understand
what objectively is means
you're not going to interpret anything
you're just going to take what's
in front of you okay now what do they do
next well they say this
is what we call a hypercube or
a tesseract and they have these uh
cubes and i don't know they pull them
out of the
the magic uh hat you know
the top hat they waved their magic wand
they pulled all these cubes out of there
and you said well where did all those
cotton picking cubes come from
i mean you know this is a thousand
clowns coming out of jack-in-the-box
that's all it is
there's no justification for this and
again it's people who
um have a lot of uh
uh what is it uh fancy
stuff in their heads you know uh not
science but science
fiction lots of fiction in their heads
and so they see more than
what's in there okay they just say oh
yeah we pull a box here we pull another
there
and there you have your hypercube you
know i mean
it has nothing to do with science or
with physics okay
that's uh magic that's all it is what is
a hypersphere again
the same as a hypercube and they
illustrate it like that like
in this case three nested spheres uh
transparent so that you can see the
inner ones
what it is is really a growing sphere
that's what they're
that's the notion of the hypersphere
because you have to have time
and all these people say no you don't
need time in any of these figures yeah
you need time in
all of them absolutely all of them not
one of these
because they're all built with motion so
not one of these
so-called figures is a static figure not
in mathematics
in the religion of mathematics they're
all built they're all constructed
constructed takes time and motion
all of these have time embodied in them
whether you like it or not people look
at the final product and say well that's
a square it's not moving there's no time
involved
that's a cube it's not there's no time
involved i can see the hyper
the tesseract or hypercube i can see the
hyper
sphere there as well it's like
they see it and they say see that's a
static image but that's not what is
conceptually defined
or described by mathematics when
they define and describe they get the
ones on the right
they have motion and time embodied in
all of these geometric figures
until you understand that you're just
fooling yourself
they're showing you one thing that's
that's what you have in your mind it's
like
you see the dot and you say okay i know
what a point is no that's not the point
the dot
is not the point and likewise when you
see the line of the line is not the
point the
line is not the line you have a bunch of
locations you have an itinerary you have
motion
and this is all also built on motion
they're constructed with motion meaning
time okay in fact they tell you that the
fourth dimension
is time and we'll get to that in a
second here
uh clarify that or or uh
build upon that okay okay what is a
taurus what's a donut
i like chocolate doughnuts so i put a
chocolate doughnut there i hope you
won't mind
okay um is that what they
illustrate well no that's that's too
simple and
just makes you hungry no it's the one on
the right that they like to show
the fancy one know where the little dots
roll around and they say oh look at a
taurus that's that's neat well if that's
the taurus obviously it's got
time and motion involved in it embodied
in them
you know if that's a torus and it's
twirling around
well you got time and that is what a
taurus is
a taurus is a is the same thing as uh
like a cube or a hypercube or a
hypersphere what you have is a little
dot that's going around
not thought it's really a location
that's going around in different
locations
location moving through locations right
and
building your donut and so when they
show you the final product you say well
that's a donut
yeah but that's not what a taurus is a
taurus is
something in motion it is always emotion
all the so-called geometric figures
of mathematics right
none of them are figures at all they are
all
dynamically built they're constructed
they all have
they all embody motion they all embody
time
because otherwise mathematics would have
no purpose for them mathematics cannot
use
any of the ones on the left they have no
use for the
for a static figure they have to move
around because they're going to be
measuring
along the cube the square the doughnut
they're going to be measuring interested
in what their measuring tape reads
they're not interested in the object
itself
okay so all geometric figures are built
with
motion and time and he who doesn't
understand that well
has a mental problem or he's got his
religion very deeply
deep inside him that's the only reason
you're not letting go of that because
you're trying not to understand because
it's going to destroy your religion
if you finally find out that there are
no static geometric figures in
all of mathematical physics but that's
what you got to come to grips with
because that
is exactly the case okay
um
uh one site
because we gotta show how this relates
to space time now
when one fellow he uh he points to a
site
and he says oh but there's a new version
of space time you know you have the
normal space time that everybody
uh visually sees out there okay
which is the fishnet and some a bowling
ball
you know on the on this canvas on this
trampoline and then they rolled a little
marble and says hey it goes downwards
and
and that's what gravity is and people
have that notion
but uh sometime back someone came up
with a different notion because they
said well i don't like that one that
that's uh too um so realistic
because you're saying that the earth
weighs down
space-time and then you have this
problem where the earth
has to use gravity to push space-time
downwards so this
what i call two-dimensional version of
space-time you know a lot of people
don't like that they say well you know
that doesn't really give me an idea what
gravity is
it's geometry yeah because you're
bending space-time but you know it's
like
is is that how how things work out there
in
in space and so they've come up with
a different version and this fellow uh
he
points me in the direction of a
youtube video that claims to be the
originator but
obviously it's he's not because 10 years
earlier you can find another the same
version in someone else's
youtube and so let me go with that let
me show you what this file says he says
uh says there's another version you know
update to the
elastic sheet of space-time version he
points to that website there
to that youtube site and what is it well
here it is looks more or less like this
okay this fellow you go in there and
this is what this file says he says
he first goes through newton you know he
covers that base he says free fall can
be modeled by force
the force of gravity he's referring to
newtonian force
in this case uh not force equals mass
times acceleration he's really referring
to
force equals the constant g
gravitational constant g times mass mass
divided by
distance squared that's what he's
referring to when he says force okay
this force allows us to predict the
movement of
objects stating that they are attracted
to each other
to massive objects like the earth
however this
description is uh merely
an approximation well yeah a prediction
is only a description
without more predictions just
description you're just describing for
example like i give the example
always uh that tomorrow two o'clock
there's gonna be an eclipse
so far you haven't explained why you
just gave me a description you said
tomorrow there's gonna be
this thing that's gonna happen that's
just the description
so far you haven't explained anything no
mechanism no anything
we don't know why an eclipse occurs okay
what
what triggers it to happen and uh
and yeah then he says this description
blah blah blah blah blah yeah
because that's all he has so far he has
a description
okay when you use force the word force
from mathematics
all you're doing is describing you
haven't explained anything yet
okay and you know this is one of the big
problems we have because
mathematicians don't understand the
difference between an explanation
and a description this is going to be at
the root of this whole problem
and so what does good old einstein come
up with
in contrast to mr
newton well he comes up with this okay
uh
several hundred years later 300 years
later he says
in 1915 einstein proposed a new theory
this is the same fellow that puts this
in his youtube video a rigorous
mathematical model which made
it possible to what to describe again
okay a theory and he says describe now
theories are
explanations not descriptions is
possible
uh free fall more accurately what does
accuracy have to do with a theory
we're talking about an explanation we're
not talking about how accurate your
mathematical equation or your
measurement is
this is where we have a problem these
people don't understand the difference
between
a description and a a an explanation and
they call
a description a theory okay and this is
a big problem
big problem because mathematicians have
gotten used to use using the word theory
when there is not a single theory in all
of mathematical physics
mathematics can only describe
and descriptions are not theories
theories are explanations
okay so we have to define these terms to
find out what we're talking about
and the sky continues says for einstein
there is no such thing as a force
that would act at a distance it is the
fabric of the universe itself which gets
distorted
and drags objects into a fall well there
you see it they put the bowling ball on
the canvas and the
uh little ball the what is it the golf
ball goes around
um so this is the two-dimensional
version what i call
you know you have the flat sheet and
then something bents it into the third
dimension
okay that's essentially it and then uh
the um
what is it the little uh bowling ball uh
i'm sorry the little uh
golf ball there just rolls around around
the
bowling ball um so what's the problem
the problem
is this word fabric okay so what is a
fabric what what is that fabric
and i say that's space-time well
space-time is not a fabric it's a
concept
you know uh you might have doubts on
space but hopefully nobody has
doubts on time okay there is no physical
object called time
and so this fellow is going to talk
about like every
relativist out there they're going to
talk about
bending and warping time
very scary stuff okay here he goes he
says um
he's gonna use this notion of geodesics
that i covered in the past
and i'm gonna use my uh two elephants
okay
he uses ants but it's the same notion
says objects move in a straight line but
within a curved geometry
okay what they're saying is if the two
elephants start out more or less you
know parallel like in parallel if you
drew
two tangents to the elephants they would
be in parallel but as they move along
the geodesics
on a curved surface they're going to
meet so these two
parallel lines essentially meet at
infinity or in this case at north pole
so they're not parallel okay and what
happens well
um what they're saying this is gravity
but again this is not an explanation of
how an elephant attracts another
elephant
what they're saying is that they as they
move along geodesics
they get closer to each other that's not
a cause that's not a mechanism
that's a description saying as they move
along these geodesic they end up at the
same place
okay that's that's not a cause a
mechanism uh the only way to produce a
mechanism
is to produce the physical objects that
draws the two
elephants together not saying that
because they roll a long geodesics
they get closer to each other that's not
gravity okay
uh but when he continues says one day
fall objects move straight ahead
where's straight ahead is you're
straight ahead the same as my straight
ahead
but the curvature of space-time gives us
the impression that these trajectories
are deflected again all this all these
are descriptions not
one of them is an explanation we still
don't understand what causes gravity
what causes
this pencil to fall downwards to the
floor
okay in this case to my lap
okay um so what does he have to do well
he has to
introduce time and this is where it gets
dangerous and which again confirms that
all geometries all geometric figures
so-called figures of mathematical
physics
involve time okay and he's got invoke
time no matter what okay here he is
he says the following says space time is
an object with four dimensions
i don't know of any object that is four
dimensional but since an object is that
which has shape
you're welcome to draw it i need for you
to draw a four dimensional
object okay hopefully if you can bring
it to the
conference it would be even better okay
bring one to the conference and we'll
know that
you've visualized you've imagined your
four-dimensional object
three dimensions of space but also one
of one
dimension of time what which can equally
bend and curve
now doesn't that strike you as odd he's
saying that
time there's a dimension called time
which we can bend and curve
now in uh physics we can't even bend the
dimension of length
or of width or of height i've never
tried to bend a dimension
but this guy says not only time is the
same thing as
uh one of the other dimensions but he
can bend it
my god again it just
blows your mind away what's going
through the minds of these people
faithfully rendering a fourth
dimensional geometry is strictly
impossible
no kidding you know in fact uh
good old stephen hawking says you know
you cannot even imagine a four
dimensional
object or the fourth dimension yeah
nobody can
and so you have all these people out
there who train you
how to visualize a four-dimensional
object in steps
like you know it's not like you see it
in one go like you see
i don't know a box or or a sphere or
whatever
sphere meaning a ball or whatever uh no
you gotta
learn how to see how to visualize
a four-dimensional object it takes
training they say
yeah you can't see it in one go okay and
here you have mr
uh i think uh i know the same fellow
he clarifies he says time can flow
differently depending on where
we are flow differently i didn't know
time flowed
time bends warps it flows he's talking
about a physical object
he's saying time is like a rock
it is the time component of the
curvature which explains gravity
he's going to explain gravity which is
essentially
what relativists do he's going to
explain gravity
by using time now i don't care
what you do but you can take seconds
minutes hours
years months weeks whatever unit of time
you want
you cannot explain the cause
of gravity with time no matter what
you need objects you can't do it with a
concept
and this is what these people say these
people say they can explain
gravity with time
and of course if you're going to bend
time and warp time and
put mass and gravity on top of it or
pull on it
uh yeah i guess you can do anything you
want okay because
it's irrational to begin with the apple
is moving in time he
alluding more or less to newton's apple
he he showed the apple going
on newton's uh head you know i'm going
to the earth why the apple falls and now
he's going to use that same apple
under relativity okay he says the apple
is moving in time
in time what do you mean in time is time
a
medium that you move through in it
progresses towards the future oh which
way is that
i mean please point to the future
because
you're pointing in my direction but my
future is in the opposite direction i
plan to go
to the future in that direction and your
future comes towards me
so which way is the future please point
to it
show me that forward and future
are directions okay
the curvature of space-time will
gradually bend
its trajectory between a temporal speed
towards the future
and a spatial speed towards the ground
aha so there's going to be like a
trade-off there okay the apple moves in
a straight line but the curvature of
space-time rotates the orientation
of this straight line between time and
space
the curvature of space-time generated by
the earth
has merely converted this temporal speed
into a spatial speed
they're going to switch dimensions here
they're going to turn
the temporal dimension the time
dimension and again they call it a
dimension
they're going to turn it into a spatial
dimension to them it's all the same
and you say well this guy is probably
not a degree guy maybe he doesn't have a
phd or whatever
now let's get someone who does let's get
mr stephen hawking who says exactly
the same thing as this fellow okay this
is from his famous book a brief history
of time
he says an event is something that
happens
happens and it's a it's an occurrence at
a particular
point in space and at a particular time
so one can specify it by four numbers or
coordinates okay that's what a
coordinate is to him just a number
so one can again the choice of
coordinates is arbitrary one can use
any three well-defined spatial
coordinates
and any measure of time and here it goes
in relativity there is no real
distinction between the space
and time coordinates just as there is no
real difference
between any two space coordinates
first of all uh good old hawking he had
a phd i think
you would think he'd know better he
confuses coordinates with dimensions to
him it's the same thing
and no it ain't they're not the same
thing dimension
are known as length with and height and
coordinates are known as latitude
altitude and elevation and um and
altitude
so uh they're not the same thing
coordinates point towards the object and
dimensions
point away from them because dimensions
are the
three mutually perpendicular directions
in which an object may
face or point and coordinates is
the location of it has to do with the
location of an
object with respect to three reference
point and
those three reference points have to be
perpendicular to each other
so uh no coordinates and dimensions are
not the same thing but he treats him as
the same thing he uses the
word dimension coordinate you know back
and forth alternatively like
if it didn't matter casually and uh
yeah so he says there's no difference
between a time dimension
and according in a coordinate or a
dimension a spatial dimension meaning
length with an i
he doesn't name him there but that's
what he's referring to
so yeah uh mathematics they
uh they have no differences between
coordinates and dimensions and they
treat time as as length and width and
height they don't they don't see any
difference
b why because all they're not talking
about dimensions or coordinates they're
talking about measurements
and numbers they're talking about units
they're talking about something they can
put in an equation
that's why you know the dimensions of
physics and coordinates of physics have
nothing at all to do with the dimensions
and coordinates
of mathematics which are not dimensions
or coordinates
they're known as number lines these
people are talking about number lines
and confusing them
with the dimensions and coordinates of
physics
because they want to make sure that you
understand that whatever math they do
out there
in cambridge and harvard
has something to do with physics for
otherwise their whole
language of mathematics would be totally
irrelevant
i mean what are they doing all these all
this math all these equations for
well because they say because this tells
us something about the real world
when it doesn't uh because the real word
has the world has to do with
mechanisms and these people are not
giving you a mechanism they claim they
do but then they give you the most
irrational thing they can come up with
saying that time has worked
that time is a physical object that
flows that it's warped
that you can bend that you can go
through
they're treating it like a physical
object and at the end of the
dissertation they deny it oh no no you
weren't supposed to take it literally
you know you were supposed to pay
attention to the numbers that we put
there the equations
not to take it literally like saying did
we warp
time no of course we did not but that's
that's the mechanism that they give you
and they also dismiss that and saying
well that's not important anyways
because that's philosophy
and so at the end of the show you never
know you never understood anything
you don't know what they were talking
about because none of what they said
matches
what they illustrated and uh so this
finally after doing all that uh fancy
footwork this is what he says
is the new version it's not the one
where you push down
gravity it's this three-dimensional one
where somehow this
fishnet flows into
objects that have mass and supposedly
all
uh objects out there in uh space
you know they have mass you know they
they weigh something
they're made of atoms and so somehow it
pulls this
fishnet inwards it's no longer you know
a
ball on canvas which is what i showed a
minute ago
no now it's uh this canvas moving
towards the center of the objects
of every object in the universe and so
because
everything moves towards the center and
you know like assuming this is the earth
so everything's moving towards the
center of the earth
here you have the sun everything's
moving towards the center of the sun
well then that's where the pool comes in
they say well you have the
this fish net going into the sun and
another fishnet going into
the center of the earth and that's what
pulls the earth to the sun
so we need to identify what this
physical object that they're
showing as a fishnet is we need to
identify what this is
because they're gonna it's gonna move
the earth
it's gonna affect the sun both of these
are physical objects
we can't see or touch this fishnet some
people always say oh bill we can't see
or touch your rope well can you see or
touch
this fishnet that keeps the earth from
flying out of the solar system
can you see or touch this fishnet that
is pulled
that uh pulls the earth towards the sun
and if you can't see or touch it does it
exist because that's the notion these
people have of
what an object is and what existence
means well does that fishnet exist
okay so uh those defenders of relativity
at least
they have a serious problem here because
they're not identifying what that
fishnet is
it's allegedly a physical object but we
can't see it or touch it
around the earth ortho so we thought
because then nasa sent gravity probe b
up there and they said we touched
time we touched warped
time we were able to measure warp time
because we touched it the gyroscope
moved and we uh
ascribed that motion to warped time
that's what nasa is telling you
literally
okay now this is not like they're using
fancy footwork and fancy wording
you know uh figures of speech no they're
saying that their gyroscopes
measured the warpage of time
that's the conclusion of gravity probe b
that's what you paid all those tax
dollars
for you know that's what they found out
for you thanks to your generous
contribution
okay um
uh oh sorry got wrong
did put that one up there okay so here
is
uh the other version okay
uh so that you i know i i showed the
version earlier now this is uh my
criticism of this okay
let me pull this down okay so uh the
question is what are those lines uh that
make up this
3d fish net because so far we see 3d we
don't see any 4d anywhere
object and so we need to identify what
that 3d
fishnet is what it's made out of what
entity causes them to drift towards the
earth
i mean what's pulling on that towards
the center of the earth
why is it going in that direction why is
that going the opposite direction
are objects physically attached to these
lines in other words
if if if the sun is attached to this
fishnet and the earth is attached to
this fishnet well we can
imagine you know that the sun is being
pulled by the earth and the earth by the
sun
right there's a mutual attraction
because they're both connected to the
fishnet
and the fishnet is going towards the
center of each one of these two
celestial objects
we all can figure that out the question
is what is this fishnet
why can't we see or touch it okay and
uh and again you have to identify it is
it a physical object
if not what is it is it a concept
okay and so this is not a geometric
theory even
in the best of cases okay or even an
explanation of a mechanism
because if that fishnet is made of time
as they say
and what you have is warped time then
you're not talking about geometric
figure what you're talking about is the
flow
of um of time time is somehow
pushing or pulling objects because it
flows
so what these people are saying either
time pulls or
more likely pushes objects towards the
center of the earth because
time is warped there's a flow of time
pushing on this pencil
that's what push it down it's the
warping of time
and because time flows and they tell you
that time flows
this object is being pushed by the flow
of time
there is no other way to interpret that
and again what they do is they
turn time into a physical object in
order to get their physical
interpretation across
that's got to be understood by a
rational person irrational people will
never understand it
okay okay
what really is space time let's find out
okay here we have it this is
again from uh mr hawking stephen hawking
even a point in space time specified by
its time
and place that's in his uh glossary
uh space time the four-dimensional space
whose points are events okay
so event is a point in space time and
space time is a bunch of
events a bunch of points in space that
and so what is an event an event is
something that this is in the body of
his book
a brief history of time an event is
something that happens
at a particular point in space in a
particular time
so one can specify with four numbers or
coordinates a four-dimensional space
called space-time
it is impossible to imagine a
four-dimensional space
that's called the ether and that's what
he's defined if we're talking about
points in space-time
and space-time is made of points well
all they did was describe the ether
which is a bunch of particles that
fill space that's what ether is
fills or is space because they have two
versions as well there but
there you have it that's what uh that's
what the
good old hawking defined
and you say well that's your
interpretation bill
now let's let's get someone with a
little more power than uh hawking how
about uh
mr einstein himself okay here it is this
is what good old einstein said uh
well back in 1920 he says we may say
that according to the general theory of
relativity space is endowed with
physical
qualities in this sense therefore there
exists an ether according to the general
theory of relativity
space without ether is unthinkable
so yeah uh the ether is a bunch of
particles that's what it is
in uh einstein's version it fills space
other people say that space is the ether
is the bunch of particles
in which case they have to identify the
medium
or thing or whatever they want to call
it that separates one particle from the
other
we need to find out what that black
stuff that separates two
white particles is okay and so that's
where
they're at okay my conclusions on all of
this
very sad conclusions okay
conclusion no figures in mathematics
okay
uh geometry there are no figures in
there no
points no lines none of those are
figures okay so we don't have
figures what we have is locations and
itineraries
and uh so math fizz is based on
geometry especially general relativity
and it's based on
irrational foundations because we don't
have a single object
physics is done with objects and they
don't have a single object what they
have is
locations and itineraries okay
space time is alleged to be a geometric
theory of gravity
right that's what they claim that's what
they boast about
2d space time which is space and time
you know the flat
uh canvas that where you're going to put
the bowling ball
that's uh what we'll call 2d space time
invokes newtonian gravitational force
something pulls that bowling ball
downwards it's known as gravity and we
have no problem understanding what
they're showing
because the bowling ball is pushing the
canvas downwards what they should do
all always so that people get a shock
you know
and wake up they should put it upside
down because there is no direction in
space
right and so why don't they put the
canvas upwards
right and the bowling ball pushing the
canvas
upwards then people would say hey that's
a little counter-intuitive there
then they would wake up to what these
people are doing
everybody can understand bowling ball on
canvas going
downwards no one can understand bowling
ball pushing the
canvas upwards that's where people would
wake up and say oh hold it that's
counterintuitive what do you mean the
bowling ball
pushes up upwards and what are you going
to say well it's gravity
uh gravity always goes downwards that's
what they would tell you
but people are not aware they're fooled
by the images
okay again you know all the images that
they put out there have nothing to do
with
the mathematical descriptions or with
their uh
definitions and uh so how about 3d space
time which is the one going
into the center of the earth you know
this flow of time into the center of the
earth
well time flowing and dragging objects
towards the earth's center
that also invokes force because you got
to tell me
what that time is what is that object
please identify that object
and it's got to be connected somehow you
know it's got to be glued
to the object to pull it or or or
then you have to push it you know you
have to have time push it towards the
center of the earth that's what these
people are
saying okay and again
if that's the case it's not a geometric
uh
explanation what it is is newtonian
force
because you're pushing uh you know the
pencil towards the center of the earth
in in the basically you could also be
pulling you know from the earth but
that's usually not what they talk about
what they're saying is the uh time is
flowing and pushing uh the pencil
towards the center of the earth
and so you gotta identify that physical
object they call time that you can warp
that is a medium you know it gets down
to the word time what
what do you mean by time what is this
physical object you call time
is it if it's an object we can
understand a mechanism if it's a concept
all you're doing is describing
and then space time is an irrational
mathematical concept
space time you put them together you
take nothing
and a concept called nothing
well time is is really
it involves memory it's motion with
memory essentially
and so you take those two you put them
together you make a physical object
called space time that you can warp
bend an orb and so on
over my head it is irrational to propose
that mass or gravity can bend a concept
such as time
and that is exactly what these people
are saying and what they say is bill
you're taking it too
literally you know that was just an
analogy
an analogy of what
is the answer to that question or to
that statement
okay let me get on with a couple of the
questions and that people asked
comments that people made regarding
subjects related to physics uh
one problem says i understand that
shadows are not physical objects i
understand that shadows are not
standalone objects
every shadow is connected to the object
that is blocking light
good we're done period and the guy
continues says however
when i look at a shadow i see shape
this is a contradiction to me and i
don't understand
uh why did you introduce an observer
that's where the problem is the problem
is you see
say i see no no
shape is not something you see okay so
please remove the observer
shape is what an object has all on its
own before any human was born on earth
the moon had shaped before any human saw
it
it already had shape okay you say how
did you know that uh
did you see it no no the moon had shape
before we saw it
it was an object before we saw it and
people don't understand that
that's where the problem is the problem
is people want to introduce observers
because they
have been drilled to exhaustion that an
object is that which
which you can see or touch and that
you're going to discover
objects by going to the lab and running
an experiment which you can see your
touch
and that anything that exists is that
which you can see your touch
and yet hopefully air exists and you
cannot see it and there are objects you
can't touch
like the the table that the klingon has
on the other side of the universe or the
table i'm thinking of you can't touch
those objects
and uh certainly this one doesn't exist
but the one that the
klingon has on the other side of the
universe that one exists
and you can't see or touch it so no an
object is not that which you can see or
touch an object is that which has shape
all on its own before
any human was born on earth
okay and here we see uh this shadow
okay and me and my shadow here you have
a box and it has a shadow
uh here on earth because you have the
sun it's uh
the box is um uh blocking the
light from the sun and so it creates
this thing we call shadow and
umbra or penumbra or whatever you want
to call it and but when you put that box
out in space and
far away in the middle of between two
galaxies or whatever
uh the shadow disappeared the box is
still there
but there's no shadow now okay
so uh does the shadow exist without the
box
uh the answer is no okay and so shadows
don't exist
shadows don't have shape because you
have to have
shape all on your own and it's not what
you see
that has shape the object has shape all
on its own before
you see it hopefully otherwise it's not
an object by definition an object is
that which has shape
all on its own independent you know
stand-alone
anyway you want to phrase that and we do
not have to specify
that in the definition that's another
long story
we just say an object's that which has
shape and hopefully you understand that
it's a standalone
object and we don't define shape either
because we're just
trying to get a definition for the word
object when for that we have to find
the right criterion and there are
different criterion out there that
people have
among them motion volume
mass see touch there's a whole bunch of
them out there
and none of them qualify in science
or physics for the purposes of physics
okay and
this file says i send the laser beam to
a moon mirror
reflect it to a space mirror and reflect
it back to earth
if light consists of screw turns screw
turns
i like that in electromagnetic ropes
would the laser beam always hit the
space mirror after it hits the moon
mirror
um that's a prediction
we don't do predictions in science okay
we don't we don't run experiments in
science you gotta learn the scientific
method first before
uh you put a comment or ask questions uh
you're you're talking about something
future here about an experiment you're
gonna run you wanna know what the result
of that experiment
is we don't do that we explain
consummated events
you tell us what the result is and we'll
explain what happened how's that
for science okay and so yeah let me just
put that briefly up here i think i've
got it here somewhere um
i think this is it
so we have it in the right context okay
we have uh
astrologer there we don't do astrology
okay
uh and it would really uh help if you
begin by explaining uh
it with your one-way particles and waves
if you don't like the
rope fine no problem uh please explain
the same thing with particles and waves
one way particles in waves see the rope
is a two-way mechanism
and you know no mathematical physics can
explain with one-way particles or waves
so begin there if you're so intelligent
and you
have problems with a rope please explain
it first with particles and waves
because if we can eliminate those then
you have no other choice but to go with
a rope
there is no other possibility out there
in
in the universe okay or that you can
imagine
uh okay so it says changing the location
of the mirrors during the
space beam trip shouldn't matter oh why
wouldn't it matter
you know it should uh if you're changing
atoms from one location to another
hopefully that changes the rope that's
connected to
that that specific atom what happens if
i turn the space mirror around
in just a split second while the laser
beam is still traveling towards it
again we don't do predictions we don't
do experiments okay you gotta tell us
what the result is and we explain
why that happened that's the way it is
okay we don't do
uh astrology you're in the wrong
business bud
and then it says down at the bottom why
would the laser beam hit the
back of the mirror if the laser beam is
traveling along an
electromagnetic rope that's connected to
the front of the space mirror just a
split second ago
well what happens here this is an
explanation type question okay and he's
saying that if he uh
tilts the uh the mirror faster than the
laser beam can reach it or in the middle
of it trying to reach it
uh that now it's gonna hit the back of
the mirror instead
of the front of the mirror well we don't
talk about mirrors in this case we got
to talk about atoms
we got to know where each atom is and
for that changing the location
of mirrors in other words the atoms does
matter
so where he got this idea that it
doesn't matter well i don't know
it does matter you know if you change
the location of an atom
the rope is attached to that atom
hopefully the
rope moved with that atom okay
and there's two versions of that but i'm
not going to cover that right now
but yeah if the atom moves so does the
rope that's connected to it
and again uh the torsion there uh a
third point
on the right torsion reaches both atoms
front and back
okay so it doesn't just reach
the uh one you know when you turn the
mirror around
it's gonna reach both atoms because it's
already connected there
okay it's just that the atoms are now at
different locations
and the issue here is the reflection in
other words it's going to take that
signal
that that torsion that just reached that
atom is going to
reflect back and so it depends
on where the atoms are okay what the
tilt is
a lot of things it depends on you got to
go with a specific
very specific case here okay to find out
what's going to happen
okay but again uh first we don't we
don't say
what's going to happen we say we try to
explain what did
happen uh science only deals with past
events with consummated events it
doesn't deal with future
events so you got to learn the
scientific method before you
put a comment or question right or you
got to phrase it in such a way that
you know that it that you have something
to explain
that's the issue otherwise it's not a
scientific question
we don't do predictions here and just in
case here let me put the scientific
method
okay so that you know what we're talking
about this is the scientific method
you don't see the word prediction there
you don't see the word experiment there
you don't see the word observation
in there we don't use our eyes we use
our mind
okay we try to think and visualize how
a mechanism works out there and so for
that you have to present
the objects the definitions and the
initial scene
as we call it the first frames of the
film uh which we call the statement of
the facts okay you gotta state the facts
uh the way you see them and you're gonna
make
assumptions on those facts and then
obviously in order to do that you if
you're going to do physics you've got to
present the objects
and the definitions that you're going to
work with okay
and what is this about well it's because
it's science is rational explanations
you're going to explain something that's
science
science is not a description science is
not observation gawking as we call it
science is not running an experiment
without understanding what
caused it to happen what caused the
result none of that is science anybody
can do experiments yeah i can
i can mix uh the blue liquid in the red
liquid and
you know in a test tube and have an
explosion great
do i get a noble for that or do i get a
noble for explaining why that happened
how it happened because anybody can
you know bump against the wall and say i
discovered the wall
does that make you a genius
no genius is explaining something you
gotta explain
something about you know you hitting
yourself against the wall why you got a
bump on the head
maybe or whatever then then you can have
something to explain but to say that you
bumped the wall and discovered the wall
that's not science and that you did such
for such energy
in such mass nonsense no
science is about explaining and so you
got to phrase your questions
in a scientific way that you have
something to explain
and then you know uh the explanation is
what really where
science really vibrates you know and uh
that's
in the case of physics you have to
explain uh
a cause or mechanism that's what it is
that's what science is about that's what
physics is about
okay and final question common here
uh fellow says he says how do you have
gas pressure gradient in a vacuum
another fellow answered him says earth
holds on to particles via
the uh rose okay that's a good synthesis
and fellow says yeah but i can't it
can't be proven
nor replicated that's the problem i have
uh that's a problem of um belief
and we don't do that that's religion
belief is religion
you have a problem with belief not with
uh if you want something proven to you
okay or replicated meaning go to the lab
and see and touch it
that's all belief that's all religion we
don't do that in science and science
what we do
we explain why the cause and we
there there you see the cause you see
the explanation
which is what this foul said says all uh
atoms are connected physically connected
by
ropes electromagnetic ropes very thin
very
uh lengthy uh
[Music]
thin small whatever you want to call it
uh
elongated ropes electromagnetic ropes
two twine
threads we can't see or touch them okay
we say that up front we can't see or
touch them much like space time you
can't see or touch it but they claim uh
it holds the earth to the sun
right so yeah we can't see or touch the
ropes
okay but they physically connect
uh any two atoms because the atoms
themselves are made
of those ropes so it's just a single
thread in the entire universe
and uh so if an atom is tied to the
center of the earth and the other atom
from uh the gas surrounding the earth
right known as air is tied to the center
of the earth the other atom is tied to
the center of the earth they're all
pulling inwards
and there you have the mechanism of
gravity and
as long as you understand it we're done
we're done with science
belief proof uh replication
that's religion we don't do that in
science so
uh if that's the problem you have you
have you got to take it up with your
priest on sunday
here we only talk about you know how
uh gas is pulled towards the center of
the earth
or that why there's a gradient and it's
not
pressure it's the opposite of pressure
it's pull
pressure you know you have essentially
something pushing
and that's what people have in their
mind because all the
mechanisms have forever been mediated
with
discrete particles and you can only push
with discrete particles
for the first time in history now we
have pull the force of pull
because we have an elongated uh mediator
that binds any two atoms so now we can
really talk about pull
and with that folks i will see you on
sunday and this sunday we're going to
have uh
my son anne's aunts adrian and
we're going to have the end of the month
review for this month
and that's when you can ask all the
questions you want
real time we're trying as many we'll try
to answer as many questions as we can
and we'll see you on sunday bye-bye